[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants posent waouh pas
trop d'accord mon gros nounours tu leur
montre le livre et moi je leur raconte
la suite des aventures du petit
cornichons mots le seul homme au
[Musique]
beaufort et vient à silvan annonce ne
bouge pas comme ça voilà tu est posée et
maintenant tu ne montres la suite de
l'histoire de cornichons et du chant
chez valve data avoue peu trop vous
pouvez raconter au bout patron
[Musique]
cornichons son papa sa maman dada et la
roulotte sont aujourd'hui au bord de la
mer ils sont en vacances nous nous la
maman de cornichons range ses belles
laine de toutes les couleurs
son papa treize des paniers et notre
petit cornichons fait des pâtes et aussi
chez enfer débattent et on a fait aussi
à la mer y est en train de remplir son
petit seau d'eau quand il entend une
toute petite voix qui lui dit qu'en
échange je t'en prie remet moi vite dans
la mer et il voit au fond de son saut
pour avis en minuscules poissons qui
nagent et tourne en rond un petit
poisson qui a de belles rayures de
toutes les couleurs
mais qui es tu lui demandes cornichons
je suis la jirs m répond le ravissant
minuscules poissons pauvres petites
erreurs mais cornichons qui est un
gentil petit garçon remettent aussitôt
la girelle dans la mer viens avec moi je
vais te montrer ma maison la girelle
nages a trop vite corniche on la suit le
long de la plage les pieds dans l'eau
les chaussures à la main et ils vont
ensemble très très loin il arrive à la
maison du petit poisson lui dit la
girelle heureuse d'être revenue chez
elle et elle donne à notre petits
cornichons tout une pleine poignée de
perles fines des précieuses
ok c'est gentil il en a de la veine de
cornichons écoute le sud deux au repos
corniche on est ravi il n'a jamais vu
des billes aussi belle il remercie son
ami jirel lui dit au revoir et s'en va
vite car il veut montrer ses belles
perles à son ami dada yvan six ans non
j'ai envie un simple mais corniche on ne
retrouve plus son chemin
il est tellement discret et il marche
longtemps longtemps les pauvres s'est
perdue il ne retrouve plus sa roulotte
sa maman son ami dada qui le cherche
partout et ils marchent si loin qu'il
s'endort de fatigue
et il n'entend pas la musique que son
papa joue pour lui pour petits
cornichons
c'est vrai mon port du voile est ce que
c'est qu'à partir loin que celle le faut
jamais faire comme cornichons les petits
c'est très drôle de nom n'est plus un
jeu là là
[Musique]
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
elle vous a plu ah oui elle est très
jolie cette histoire merci des marchands
de farbus voulons les [ __ ] ou doutons
[Musique]
pas du tout grand les noces pas nui hugo
la bonite apprenait dors bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit petit pimprenelle bonne nuit
petit nicolas bonne nuit tous les
enfants allaient sagement vous coucher
et faites de beaux rêves
faute de bord nous voyons pas trop alors
en route mon cher nounours bon et nuit à
demain au togo
[Musique]